there are a lot of sources of brain fog
the most obvious one would be a poor
night's sleep sleep of course being the
most fundamental layer of mental and
physical health you don't sleep well for
one night you're probably okay for two
nights you start to fall apart three
four nights you're really a degraded
version of yourself in every aspect
emotionality is off ability to do most
anything is off hormones start suffering
so sleep is is fundamental but assuming
that you slept well there are a number
of things one is your breathing patterns
we often get into discussions of
breathing but this is a slightly
different one than we've had in the past
a lot of people have sleep apnea they
are not getting enough oxygen during
their sleep or they are mouth breathing
during sleep these days it's become
popular in some circles to take a little
bit of medical tape and tape the mouth
shut and to learn to be a nasal breather
there is excellent evidence now that
being a nasal breather most of the time
as long as you're not speaking or eating
or exercising hard enough that you would
need to breathe through your mouth that
it's beneficial to be a nasal breather
for a couple of reasons first of all if
you are deliberately nasal breathing
during the day the tendency is that you
will nasal breathe at night which tends
to lead to less sleep apnea less mouth
breathing during the middle of the night
and less brain fog need motivation watch
Ed on Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of
one of Dr Andrew huberman and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
why brain fog well during sleep a number
of restorative processes occur but if
you're not getting enough oxygen into
the system the brain is literally
becoming hypoxic and a lot of the
cleaning out mechanisms that the
lymphatic system Etc as they're called
don't get an opportunity to function as
well as they ought to so you wake up in
the morning you slept your normal six to
eight hours but you're feeling kind of
groggy and out of it and of course there
could be other reasons that you're
experiencing brain fog maybe you know
for people that drink alcohol the night
before maybe they had alcohol for people
that maybe they ate a meal that was too
large before sleep maybe any number of
reasons right gotcha but
um getting adequate oxygenation of the
brain during sleep is key so learn to be
a nasal breather and for those of you
out there that say well I have a
deviated septum a lot of people think
they have deviated septums the problem
is they're not nasal breathing enough
the sinuses actually can learn to dilate
if you nasal breathe exercising while
nasal breathing it will kind of depend
on the sport like if you box oftentimes
there's the need to do a sh or you know
kind of like exhale on impact type thing
so I I don't think anyone should tamper
with their normal breathing patterns as
it relates to sport or singing or some
you know activity but what I'm talking
about is when you're just standing
around when you're walking down the
street any low level activity you're
working at your desk yeah you should be
nasal breathing and breathing regularly
that will reduce brain fog in many cases
rule number two improve your stress
response exploring in humans is the
extent to which people who can take on
adaptive decisions can take that
adaptive behaviors can take that stress
response and kind of move the Horizon in
closer and just focus on okay I'm in a
high stress regime this is really
painful we see this in uh we work on
people generalizing anxiety who are
trying to overcome fear of heights and
just walking across a virtual height
plank can be terrifying for them but if
they can get one step in front of the
other despite high levels of anxiety
they can eventually overcome that and so
we've been looking at everything from
how breathing affects the anxiety
response to heart rate pupil size Etc
I'd be happy to talk about all that in
as much detail as you like but I think
the principle to take away is this that
the growth mindset is not about
suppressing anxiety so that you're able
to move cruise through things with ease
that's just one part of it it's really
about trying to understand that stress
response as key to your growth it's
absolutely key and I think people that
you know that lift weights or run long
distance or are involved in competitive
Sports they fundamentally understand
stand this but even they kind of migrate
away from it over time where we recovery
is super important but you need the
stimulus right and the stimulus for
growth is that stress response and if
you think about it
evolutionarily let's say we were all
living in a little Clan here in the onit
offices and we didn't know anything
about the outside world we would start
to kind of eventually what drove people
to leave was they didn't have enough of
what they needed there's this sort of
the seeking right so if you had enough
everything you had enough mates enough
food enough water be fine but at some
point there was some deprivation and so
we had to do a risk benefit analysis and
so it was really about taking that
anxiety and venturing out into the
unknown to find resources some people
died and some people succeeded and they
were rewarded and with that reward came
the idea that ah there's something about
looking out into the environment that's
useful that can allow me to have more
than I have in the moment but you can't
divorce yourself from the anxiety of
wondering whether or not things are
going to turn out okay you can't divorce
yourself from the anxiety of of strain
and effort there's just simply no way
and in fact you weren't really designed
to do it so to kind of peel this around
to a practical answer because I often
listeners and you know and people want
to know what do I do with this is you
know I think
the field of wellness and biohacking and
high performance is great but it lacks
definition so one thing I'd really like
to see more of in the in these
communities and in the scientific
Community for that matter is more
careful definition like what is
mindfulness like really what are we
really talking about what is stress and
what are stress mitigation processes
that are useful so one thing I think is
really useful is think about real-time
tools versus offline tools I believe
personally that everybody whether not
their MMA fighter they're in a CrossFit
they're running Ultras or they're a
student in class that doesn't do
anything physical whatever it is has
four tools one tool to get you to
mitigate your stress response in real
time so let's say the stress response
hits you need to keep it you can't let
it go too high or too low you know you
don't want to suppress it but something
to do that you also probably want an
offline tool that allows you to raise
your ceiling on what stress feels like
you know I'm buds with whim and I've
known him for a long time and like you
know I think Wim Hof breathing is in
particular is a use useful tool for kind
of Shifting your perception of what
stressful is that's an offline tool it's
not you can do it in real time but it's
not you're not going to start Wim
hoffing in the middle of your like
rolling Jiu Jitsu because your breathing
has got to be devoted to other things so
you need offline tools and real-time
tools to cope with stress and I think
people need real-time tools and offline
tools to bring themselves into
heightened states of arousal right so
there are times when there's when you're
actually too low on the arousal plane
and the key is to get higher up there
where you can access even better levels
of performance and so I think the the
so-called autonomic nervous system it's
absolutely under our control it's a
total misnomer it's just that your heart
rate and your breathing are taken care
of on their own you don't need to flip
the on switch you wake up every morning
and you know if everything's going well
you're breathing and your heart rate is
going the way it should but you
absolutely have levers that you can
control and move in order to shift those
and I think that
um there's been a lot of focus on like
okay breathing is a great tool or you
know the ice bath is a great tool but we
really aren't thinking about what
they're best for and as a result of that
I don't think they'll ever evolve past
where they are unless we start thinking
okay like what's the utility of breath
holds no one can tell me like so my lab
is very interested in like in trying to
figure out what the utility of breath
holds is is it better at letting you
deal with adrenaline in your system is
it better at get carbon dioxide
tolerance you know
um for all the the incredible tools that
are out there there isn't a lot of good
information about systematic ways to
approach it and I don't want to peel
everything down to like a really
reductionist approach you know I'm
friends with Brian McKenzie and those
guys and you know Brian's about as
reductionist as you get in the
breathwork community and I love how
quantif you know how he loves to
quantify everything it's one of the
things that initially brought us
together
um as friends and as uh as you know sort
of informal collaborators but I think
that this world of biohacking needs
definition you know it's it's kind of
ironic that in the weightlifting
Community they've really works things
down to a kind of a fine science whereas
in the endurance Community it's kind of
like
whoever you're listening to seems to be
the person who knows the most and I
don't claim to know everything or the
most at all I just would like to see
sharper definition on all this stuff
about stress stress mitigation ice baths
breathing and so on rule number three
pursue challenges the discovery of
growth mindset is worth thinking about
so Carol's Discovery was these kids that
for whatever reason you know like doing
math problems even though they knew they
couldn't get the answers right these
were sure fail problems so it's the same
kind of people that like doing puzzles
and these kids not surprisingly go on to
do phenomenally well in a number of
different areas of academic Pursuit you
know but what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain so the action or the pursuit
of a goal not just achieving a goal and
when we step back and we look at what
that really entails at a neurochemical
level we have reward systems in the
brain they generally fall into two
categories they're the reward systems
that make you feel really good with kind
of the here and now and everything
that's within the confines of your skin
and the things you already have you know
love of your dog love of your spouse
gratitude for all the things you happen
to have and and those are generally
governed by the release of molecules
like serotonin and oxytocin okay but
then there's another reward system which
is the one that drove a lot of human
evolution which is the dopamine reward
system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
I'm going to work to this goal I'm going
to build my company I'm going to you
know get 10 years of press whatever it
is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards now the ability
to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this covered you know pandemic
situation the but the amazing thing is
remember the brain only does five things
and we get to decide which of those
Sensations and perceptions have
relevance and which ones don't or which
ones are attached to a goal and which
ones aren't so growth mindset in its
purest form is the attachment of these
reward systems to the effort process to
the friction process and not just to
obtaining a reward and just as a kind of
final point to that there's a very um
well-known body of literature and
Neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists that talks about
something called reward prediction error
and it says if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too where you're in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this is gonna be great and then you
reach that goal and it's kind of
underwhelming and that generally
triggers this this circuit that I
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself I'm on the right track
this friction I'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good I'm going to tell myself this
is for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we were talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in Pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine rule number four keep goals in
your mind we've all heard the sayings
you know how do you you know Journey Of
A Thousand Miles starts with a single
step or how do you eat an elephant one
bite at a time or you know they're all
these sayings and and it goes back to
the Bible and earlier right I mean this
is not new these are not new sayings but
they're showing up in different forms
what's lost in those short descriptions
however is that every step is not
equivalent if it were just at a journey
of a Thousand Miles starts with a single
step everyone would pursue their goals
everyone would push back against
adversity everyone I mean you can read
the inspirational stories as many times
as one needs and I do think
inspirational stories are a very high
value in fact I think they're vicarious
dopamine I think they give us the sense
that we could which then orients hope
which then orients us to the world to
start yeah maybe it's possible for me
that's right so let's say um let's take
the example of somebody who's
um but there's a thing is that's that
story of it's not about just taking a
single step and one step at a time
is it because there's adversities every
10 steps you go and so it's harder and
harder so it's not just well it's just
very non-linear you know it's it's some
days ago you know I know this from a
scientific career it's you know some
days it's easy some day is hard it's all
over the place right so I think the
thing to remember is that dopamine is
this incredibly powerful molecule that
allows us to buffer the effort process
it allows us to be an effort longer and
it allows us to actually eventually
enjoy the process of effort and not
think about the reward but just say oh
I'm enjoying the process right well you
just described the first step the first
step in learning to attach dopamine to
the effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming and
depressing and I'm not good enough
that's right I should just give up what
am I doing this for that's right it's
thoughts will affect us and they're very
realistic right I mean as Carol will say
and other people said in the psychology
field you know positive self-talk
oftentimes unless you do it correctly
you're badly wrong you know lying to
yourself won't work saying saying I'm
I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm a winner
or you haven't won yet is is great but
that's not the most effective use of
these systems well you're also being out
of Integrity with yourself you're you're
telling yourself a lie right you're like
and then you're losing your ability to
have confidence because you you just
lined yourself right and if it's really
extreme there's a name for it it's
called delusional right right and people
will start to point that out and then it
becomes harder to recruit people into
your your goals so I think the key thing
is to attach that sense of reward to the
effort process it's saying look
I am oriented in the right direction and
rewarding the things you're not doing
I'm not back on my heels I'm not just
staying you know I'm better anymore yeah
a good example this came to me recently
I have a good friend he did nine years
in the SEAL Teams his name is Pat
dossett and and we were talking about
you know the Admiral mccraven thing you
know get up and make your bed and you
know and they they really do that and I
think the way it was described was
um you know so at the end of the day
even if everything doesn't go well your
bed is still made for me that's not that
big of a reward frankly right but I and
so I said that and I I love it though I
make my bad oh I definitely made my bed
in the morning but I mean going back and
seeing that at the end of a hard day
it's not enough I felt like there was
something else there so I asked him he
said well it's very interesting because
part of it is about not just making your
bed but it's the things you're not doing
by making your bed you're not lying in
bed and ruminating you're not back on
your heels you're on your phone that's
right yeah when so when you look at and
you have spent a lot of time with people
in high performing communities
mainly through some Consulting work but
what you find is that you know we can
all be either be back on our heels
flat-footed or forward Center or mass
and when you look at people who are in
these high performance communities they
try and keep their Center of mass
forward
almost through what seemed like trivial
things like making your bed or making
the cup of coffee but it's not just
about what you're doing it's all the
things you're not doing interesting that
can put you down the path of ruminating
or put you down the path of
um unhealthy Behavior so the key to this
is if we want to be very concrete we
should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas young
people's circumstance is different let's
say somebody really wants to take on a
fitness routine they hate running or
they want to lose weight in a healthy
way this kind of thing so we've all
heard the example well you put your
shoes by the door on day one day two you
put them on day three you go out the
door day four you walk around the block
and then you know and then eventually
like they're running marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the the behavior
pleasureful and to give you energy the
key is to subjectively reward those
steps so it's not going to be let's say
I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with the single is made up
of you know single steps but the key is
to reward the harder steps not the
easier ones and not the ones where you
get the thing that you want don't reward
yourself for putting your shoes on and
taking a step outside you could if that
was a huge barrier for you it was very
hard it is very hard for you running the
10 miles that's hard find the wall
and push a little bit further through
that wall and reward that process so
this is why I think reps in the gym the
final reps like reps to failure
are usually not the best example first
of all most people aren't doing reps to
failure and it doesn't translate to
young kids and stuff where they probably
shouldn't be doing heavy reps to failure
this kind of thing what you want however
is if you're going to go there to think
about these are the this is the hard
part because that's when adrenaline
norepinephrine are getting maxed out and
that's when you have an opportunity to
bring dopamine in and teach those neural
Pathways to slam that back down and
I don't want to um highlight them too
much because they are a very Niche and
specialized Community but if you look at
people in Special Operations you look at
the
um process like the whole evaluation
process of who gets in and who doesn't
it's really about putting people into
stress and seeing who can not just make
it through that stress but buffer that
stress reward the process through
teamwork reward the process of stress
through some internal dialogue that has
everything to do with not being back on
your heels not being flat footed but
Center or mass forward and I should also
be clear I'm not talking about everybody
being super aggro and always like you
know work work yeah in fact if you're
spending too much epinephrine if you're
too much of an adrenaline junkie you
will burn out eventually unless you can
find ways to recover yourself or to
buffer that with dopamine and the
recovery process is especially important
there's a second reward system so you've
got the dopamine system and I guess to
really put a box around it the
subjective reward needs to be done at
the hardest portion of a process the
tough conversation with a significant
other it's like when it's really tough
and you want you just that's when you
want to start telling yourself this is
the this is the good part because I'm
not speaking or this is the car because
I think right I'm not reacting or this
is the good part because I'd probably
not doing it correctly but I'm on the
right path right
um they're upset they're not feeling
your empathy you know this kind of thing
or you're not really understanding
what's going on you're getting
frustrated but if you tell yourself this
is this is the neural pathway getting
ground in there like it really dialed in
so that the the next time this I'm going
to Breeze right past this that's really
how the process works because dope
remember no one comes along and drips
dopamine in your ear even if you get a
billion dollars or you win a Nobel Prize
or you win the presidency it's all
internal these neurochemicals are all
internal and while some of them are
designed to be released in response to
things very reflexively like um you know
food sex sleep you know all these things
will trigger these neurochemicals we
have this big forebrain which allows us
to place subjective context on things
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five interact with
other people and whether or not that
competition is with you know mental
material like books and studying or
whether or not it's physical competition
we need external influences like I think
we these days we're so attracted to the
idea that we can you know control
everything from the inside but you need
human interaction uh it's absolutely
necessary and I think that
um you know it sort of Harkens back to
the story at the beginning it's like all
the the stress and that I was going
through in those years I mean it
absolutely made me better right
absolutely maybe I wouldn't trade it for
anything I don't wish hardship on people
but humans are remarkable in their
ability to step into Challenge and to
meet challenge you know I think that
there's this important and very very
serious conversation now about mental
health right the number of people
suffering is just tremendous but I think
that we also are forgetting that you
know that suffering process is is it's a
jumping off point right and I've had a
number of friends commit suicide I
understand just how you know that's
that's a horrible tragedy and depression
is absolutely terrible but there's also
this question of you know sort of like
what is our expectation about our mood
right like we're so what are we really
what are we really trying to achieve
with our moods and so I always say you
know there are five things that embody
our whole existence it's like our
Sensations what we feel our emotions our
perceptions our thoughts and our actions
that's pretty much it and of all of
those the emotions are the most
mysterious it's like it's kind of a
combination of perception and thoughts
you know you can control your behavior
you can control your thoughts people
often forget this but your thoughts are
your choice right I'm not saying you can
suppress thoughts I think there's been a
lot of attention on trying to learn how
to suppress thinking I've never been
able to suppress thinking ever but what
I can do is introduce new thoughts
actually Stephen pressfield who wrote
The War of art
brilliant author and ex-military eye he
he really I think he said something like
you know he was like in his mid-40s
before he had his first real thought and
what I like to think he was referring to
was the first time that he realized that
you could actually introduce a thought
that thoughts aren't just all
spontaneous so they can be deliberate
you know your Sensations you can control
by your environment and your perceptions
are largely about kind of like what
sends you you know your thoughts about
what you sense right but your feelings I
think we overvalue feelings and here I'm
going to come across as you know kind of
a hardened male and about this I you
know I would place myself actually kind
of on the wide emotionality scale but
I've learned over the years that
emotions are just kind of a mishmash of
perception and thought I think we over
we overvalue their utility and this is
just my opinion I don't have any
scientific data to support it but I also
don't even know how you study emotions
in the lab every time I see a laboratory
that claims they study emotions they're
studying Behavior every time there's I
you know people are talking about fear
and about courage they're talking about
a behavior that's measured we don't know
what these animals feel they don't have
the foggiest I don't know what you feel
right now I barely understand what I
feel right now so I think that as a
species we've been and in terms of
mental mental health we we've been over
focused on feelings and I think we need
to think more carefully about physiology
rule number six break addiction to
negativity everyone knows that the brain
is very plastic early in life so from
birth until about age 25 you can learn
so much for Better or For Worse I always
say the downside is that early in life
you're you have less control over your
life circumstances but your brain is
very plastic so there's a you know dark
and light to that later in life you have
a lot more control generally over your
life circumstances but the brain becomes
less plastic however we know based on
Nobel prize winning work and recent work
in addition to that that the
neuromodulator acetylcholine is secreted
when we pay attention to something very
specific it acts as sort of a spotlight
in the brain making certain synapses the
connections between neurons more active
and more likely to be active again than
others so when you hear that song that
you love so much and it moves you and
you feel dopamine being pulsed into your
body that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you've formed
that deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially wired
in a very indelible way into your
nervous system at multiple you can
probably even with certain songs you can
feel your body start to energize because
of course the brain through connections
with your muscles controls your body so
for things that are traumatic or
negative what we're really talking about
is neuroplasticity that's focused on
unlearning and most of the therapies for
this whether or not it's EMDR eye
movement desensitization reprocessing or
it's traditional psychoanalysis and
Psychotherapy or it's somatic embodied
release big you know Kundalini breathing
type almost all of those are designed to
do something which is to bring the
person or you bring yourself into a
state of heightened alertness right you
can't do this stuff when you're sort of
half asleep heightened alertness and
then focusing your attention on the
traumatic or negative of event this is
the way that works and then pairing that
with something new you know
traditionally this was done with things
like NLP or in talk therapy where people
would feel the relation the positive
relationship with the therapist that was
kind of the main rationale in
association with this very traumatic
sometimes even you know shameful type
events and the idea is that you you
would simultaneously have those two
experiences the negative one and the
feeling of safety and you would rewire
those circuitries I actually believe
that can work but it can take a lot of
times it can take a lot of visits to the
therapist which is not to say it's bad
it's just not everyone has access to
those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out that somehow when people
recount these traumatic experiences when
they're doing these lateralized eye
movements not vertical eye movements
they somehow separate out the negative
emotions and I thought for years people
would ask me about this stuff Tom and I
thought this is ridiculous first of all
I'm a vision scientist and I work on
stress it's like there's no way and then
I really ate my words because four
papers two Inhumans two in mice and then
a fifth paper published in nature which
is kind of our Super Bowl of scientific
publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection Center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of when the way that we view the
visual world when we move through space
when our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements are what
happens when you move forward in space
when you're walking when you're moving
forward towards something and that
suppresses activation of the amygdala
now you say why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there
was an actual graduate student in my
laboratory where we're looking at fear
in this case we're looking at fear to
Big looming objects that either trigger
freezing or running and hiding there's a
brain area that's in your brain and my
brain that mice also have that triggers
a third option not run and hide not
freeze but forward confrontation this is
the no I'm gonna fight I'm gonna move
forward in the face of adversity this is
the growth mindset I'm going to lean
into friction and it turns out that this
circuit is linked to the dopamine reward
pathway when we move forward in the face
of a threat and obviously we want to do
this in healthy adaptive ways we
suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with EMDR because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection Center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive mind
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space so to make this a
little more succinct it's really forward
movement action pushing yourself across
that threshold not only rewards you but
it suppresses activity of the fear
centers in the brain and these are
ancient hardwired mechanisms these
aren't hacks these are things that
mother nature installed in US rule
number seven avoid layering dopamine I
suggest people avoid layering dopamine
you know you have one dopamine system
that fortunately can be activated by a
lot of different things so for instance
I love the feeling of being completely
rested going into the gym or going for a
run mid-morning after a cup of coffee
hydrating well using the bathroom
listening to my favorite music on a
sunny day but that's a lot of things
layering in for dopamine and what
happens is that if that becomes your
hope and expectation fine but if that
becomes your requirement for actually
having a great
run or work out you're in trouble
because the next time you're it's not
going to be that exciting and you're not
going to be that motivated you actually
won't perform as well so this year what
I've been doing is every third or fourth
workout or so I think I'm randomly I
leave my phone in the car
I don't use any music and I don't allow
myself any kind of pre-workout stimulant
so I have to generate all the force and
energy and everything I'm going to do
from internal processes and you might
say well that's kind of masochistic why
would you do that it's supposed to be
fun well I'll tell you when the next
time when you bring your headphones
you're listening to music you feel like
a god in there what the real why because
you are secreting so much more dopamine
so much more noradrenaline so much more
effective at performance but then the
next time you have to throttle it back
and so I'm excited by all the tools that
are out there all the you know there's
all this like cognitive enhancement
stuff and people are you know plugging
into every device and they're trying to
figure out do I have white noise in the
background or metronomes and all that
stuff but it's good to not layer in too
many things
um there are other examples of this
where
um are a little more um unfortunate
uh pornography is a really good example
there's a huge issue now right because
pornography is so much more readily
available on the internet now let's just
remove the kind of um the moral uh
judgments about it right because that's
not what this is about a scientific
discussion about this would say that
there's an enormous availability and
range of imagery that's very powerful
that feeds directly into the dopamine
system
and a lot of people young people who are
growing up watching a lot of intense
pornography are suffering from a lot of
sexual side effects and struggles and
sexual interactions in real life because
those interactions are not as intense as
the things that they're seeing the other
thing that's happening I should just
mention is that I've got colleagues that
work on this in Psychiatry that that
they are wiring their nervous systems to
become aroused viewing other people
having
sex as opposed to them having it and so
they're running into a lot of trouble
there so what's happening is very
interesting dopamine levels are so high
that real life circle it's like it's
like eating extremely palatable foods
that are just blitzing your system every
taste bud at high salt high sugar high
fat to the point where it's just and
let's assume delicious I don't generally
like those kinds of foods but and then
all of a sudden it's like here's a bowl
of rice or a or a salad it's gonna taste
like garbage to you because you're at
first anyway that's also going to be
sort of trickling over to just social
media in general and and the dopamine
release in response to that versus say
for example a real life conversation
right well and if you're on social media
and you're scrolling and you don't even
know why you're scrolling like you don't
even know what you're looking for your
dopamine system has been tapped out and
you need to take a break from it maybe a
couple hours maybe a couple of days I
think social media is great I teach
science on social media to you all the
time on social media you know there's a
lot of great social interaction there's
a lot of opportunity to learn and see
things some are funny some are
interesting some are disturbing but when
you're at the point where you're
engaging in something and you don't even
know what the win is but you find
yourself reflexively engaging in it your
dopamine system is now plummeting and
that's a serious issue so the other
thing is that a picture is worth a
thousand words and a movie is worth a
thousand pictures
our visual system is so tuned to watch
motion and to see movies so you're
seeing movie after movie after movie
after movie what's happening is the
context is switching constantly our the
human brain has never been confronted
with context switching at this rate you
know a television you know went from you
know six channels to 12 to 200 but this
is the first time that you can walk
around with your television you can have
it in your car you can have it on the
phone excuse me on the plane so I use
social media and the internet a lot
um unlike email or reading an article
online social media is you know you can
scroll through a thousand different or a
hundred different contexts within five
minutes and that's a big override for
the brain and then the rest of the world
seems kind of boring
like you know you see people at dinner
scrolling their phone it's because
actually the brain wants novelty it's
seeking novelty all the time these days
I'm I'm turning off my phone in the
evenings I'm sort of I'm on there a
little bit but I'm finding I'm kind of
sick of the phone I think a lot of
people are kind of hitting this point
where they're like ah I'll get on social
media for an hour or two a day but this
is getting a little pointless rule
number eight keep moving forward I think
that an ability to know that things pass
an ability to know that what you're
feeling in the moment is not a permanent
State and doesn't necessarily return an
ability to know that your identity 10
years ago hopefully isn't your identity
now and you can actually transform your
identity over time is immensely powerful
it's when we get into these locked
regimes of who we are how we feel how we
think that kind of the like impending
doom really takes over not to be
dramatic about it but everyone I know
that is that isn't
able to adopt a kind of different ideas
about how things could be different on
the outside and on the inside
is suffering right and everyone I know
that has the kind of mindset
unfortunately I happen to know a lot of
people like this that understand that
yeah your internal state is something
you can shift with exercise with
movement with ice bath with breathing
with whatever your your particular
leanings are then they seem to
understand that that like grabbing hold
of that internal real estate first is
kind of a door that opens like oh my
world and my life is actually something
I completely control and so this
conversation there's this portion of the
conversation might not seem that
scientific but it's absolutely
scientific in the sense that the brain
is a time-space statistical guessing
machine it just wants to know what's
coming next that's all it wants to know
and so if you can start to expand the
notion of what's come what could come
next you really start to open up
possibility and in possibility you start
to open up the physiology of the body to
explore and in Exploration you get
different outcomes so these I think that
this kind of mystical or abstract level
of the conversation is really at the
core of what human beings are best at
which is using the front of our brain to
conceive new ways of doing things this
is like the reason we're not this is the
reason we run the planet and other
animals don't is like my dog Costello
doesn't wake up and say oh you know
I want more food so I'm here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna tomorrow you know he
just basically is like he does what he
needs to to get what he needs in the
moment we're the planners and in
planning we can do so much more but in
planning it's also where we suffer if we
plan to feel the same way so in a lot of
ways we're planning to feel the same way
rule number nine celebrate small wins
when you start thinking about things
like growth mindset in terms of how they
convert to neurochemical signatures it
leads us to this place of okay if it's
all subjective then you know if I just
say look I'm going to stand up out of my
chair and and that's going to feel
amazing is that going to work well no it
depends on the meaning that I attached
to something and this and this
subjective part can be a little tricky
and a little bit hard for people so I
want to try and lay it out in a in a
concrete way so that if they want to
apply this they can
um incidentally or not so incidentally I
should say when you look at communities
of very high performers and I'm
fortunate enough to do some Consulting
with some people from Special Forces
communities and so forth they're very
good as are you at attaching reward to
specific behaviors in subjective ways so
growth mindset and these dopamine
rewards that we subjectively apply are
not about saying oh you know I had a
terrible day I performed poorly but you
know what it's great I just feel great
anyway it's not about that it's not
about attaching your sense of reward to
the ultimate goal it's about attaching
your sense of reward to the fact that
you're making action steps that are
generally in the right direction the
more you can reward the effort process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of Tendencies to be able to lean into
anything challenging over essentially
any duration so how does this work like
how would somebody do this right well
keeping in mind that adrenaline and
epinephrine are all great for getting us
into action this is Mother Nature's Way
of chemically making us feel kind of
agitated remember stress was designed to
agitate us to move us away from things
and toward things but realizing that
that's a a limited resource that
eventually that same chemical is what
makes you have a negative mindset it
feels painful it's the burn in your body
it's uncomfortable and realizing that
dopamine can push back on that
neurochemically it can suppress those
sensations of wanting to quit you say
well then how do I get this dopamine to
work for me before I hit a goal because
not every day is going to be a real win
there's some days I mean I know from my
science career there were days that were
really hard experiments didn't work
papers got rejected and yet you know
I've spent two decades or more just
drilling on and drilling on and it's
been a sheer pleasure at times but
there's been you know some pain points
along the way so what is this process
really about and how would somebody
Implement these dopamine and epinephrine
type neurochemical events in their own
life well we all know the example of
like wanting to run a marathon I've
never run a marathon but
um that'd be a nice goal to have let's
say tomorrow morning I set my shoes near
the door now a lot of people have talked
about this day one you set your shoes
near the door day two you go out the
door day three you run around the block
day four but the key thing is not just
to go through the actions but when you
hit each one of those self-designated
Milestones the Milestones that you're
setting out for yourself you have to
pause for a moment
and tell yourself I'm heading in the
right direction I haven't run the
marathon yet but this is the foundation
upon which I'm going to lay another
Foundation upon which I'm going to lay
another foundation and those little
pulses of dopamine allow you to get that
action step without the depletion that
it would normally bring otherwise you're
just like you're spending money this is
like replenishing this bank account that
you have and it's a neural bank account
and so dopamine is the is the thing that
you can control the dosing of and so if
you say
today it's my shoes at the door but
tomorrow it's around the block and
that's it but that's in the direction I
want to go what you do is you now get
those two events plus the next day the
mile long run and so forth without it
depleting you it actually builds this
capacity to build more reward and this
is what you've done this is what people
from elite special forces can do they
know how to make small
simple
physical steps in the real world that
allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
Horizon in very close and so if you can
move the Horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that you
essentially are where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything and Rule
Number 10 and the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is learn to
focus and engage learning is a two-stage
process and the learning I'm referring
to is specifically deliberate learning
you know children are learning passively
all the time they're taking new
information their brain is it's not a
complete Tabler also it's not a complete
Blank Slate there's some hardwired
functions they show up with thank
goodness like breathing like heart rate
uh heart controlling heart rate but that
helps I mean you know offload as much as
you can to the genetic program to
hardwire the nervous system so they can
learn how to walk and walking is a good
example a a kid learns how to walk and
then walks reflexively but of course at
any stage you can think about how you're
walking you could do Hopscotch it means
you have to change your Cadence of
jumping and walking right so that's this
uh flexible
transition between voluntary and
involuntary movement but you have to
learn how to walk so but what we're
talking about now is generally
deliberate learning language learning
skill learning learning knowledge of any
kind
um learning how to you know navigate the
emotional dynamics of a relationship
well anything
two phases one is active engagement and
focus uh much of the trigger for
neuroplasticity is a process is engaged
by dopamine and norepinephrine and a
molecule called acetylcholine which is
liberated from multiple sources that we
always talked about how acetylcholine
controls the the contraction of muscles
but in the brain acetylcholine is mainly
comes from two sets of neurons one in
the brain stem and another in the basal
forebrain and it serves as a kind of a
highlighter marking particular
connections or neurons that later stand
a chance to become stronger so let me
give an example
I don't speak a second language but
let's say I decided I was going to learn
conversational French I would learn some
nouns or some verbs I would I would
focus on this and the greater degree of
focus that I bring the greater amount of
acetylcholine is released
at that time and at the particular
locations in the brain they're involved
in enunciating the words and writing the
comprehension you know multiple spots
within the brain that kind of marks
those or Flags those areas as
potentially
changing later but the actual rewiring
of the nervous system happens during
states of deep sleep or sleep-like
states and so it's so when we say
neuroplasticity the brain's ability to
change in response to experience that's
a two-part process it's a process it's
not an event we always think about
things as events but in biology almost
everything is a process so the the
takeaway from this is in order to learn
at any age the most critical thing is
that you bring as much focus and active
engagement to the learning the the
encoding of the information bringing in
the information and then that you get
into a state of deep rest as quickly as
possible typically that would be the
night after you learn uh after you have
this trigger but there are some
beautiful studies published in cell
reports last year and the year before
showing that people who take a 20-minute
nap within the four hours after these uh
triggering learning or people that do a
non-sleep deep rest type protocol even
just sitting there quietly and not doing
anything they learn much faster in other
words the brain rewires much faster
that's interesting it's very interesting
and what's happening is very interesting
we've long known that during sleep
there's a replay of the neurons in the
same sequence that they were played
during the activity in the earlier in
that day sometimes even backwards for
some reason that it's like the songs
played backwards at night who knows why
I don't think we should focus too much
on that right now but that replay is the
consolidation of the information you
learn this is why you try something
physically try it physically you can't
do it you can't do it and then you come
back a week later and voila you can do
it you had the opportunity to change the
neural circuits so that now you can do
it
acetylcholine is the neurochemical that
we want to think about anytime we're
talking about neural plasticity and in
particular attention High attentional
States so everyone knows that the brain
is very plastic early in life so from
birth until about age 25 you can learn
so much for Better or For Worse I always
say the downside is that early in life
you're you have less control over your
life circumstances but your brain is
very plastic so there's a you know dark
and light to that later in life you have
a lot more control generally over your
life circumstances but the brain becomes
less plastic however we know based on
Nobel prize winning work and recent work
in addition to that that the
neuromodulator acetylcholine is secreted
when we pay attention to something very
specific it acts as sort of a spotlight
in the brain making certain synapses the
connections between neurons more active
and more likely to be active again than
others so when you hear that song that
you love so much and it moves you and
you feel dopamine being pulsed into your
body that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you've formed
that deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially wired
in a very indelible way into your
nervous system it multiple you can
probably even with certain songs you can
feel your body start to energize because
of course the brain through connections
with your muscles controls your body so
for things that are traumatic or
negative what we're really talking about
is neuroplasticity that's focused on
unlearning and most of the therapies for
this whether or not it's EMDR eye
movement desensitization reprocessing or
it's traditional psychoanalysis and
Psychotherapy or it's somatic embodied
release big you know Kundalini breathing
type almost all of those are designed to
do something which is to bring the
person or you bring yourself into a
state of heightened alertness right you
can't do this stuff when you're sort of
half asleep heightened alertness and
then focusing your attention on the
traumatic or negative event this is the
way that it works and then pairing that
with something new you know
traditionally this was done with things
like NLP or in talk therapy where people
would feel the relation the positive
relationship with the therapist that was
kind of the main rationale in
association with this very traumatic
sometimes even you know shameful type
events and the idea is that you you
would simultaneously have those two
experience says the negative one and the
feeling of safety and you would rewire
those circuitries I actually believe
that can work but it can take a lot of
times it can take a lot of visits to the
therapist which is not to say it's bad
it's just not everyone has access to
those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out that somehow when people
recount these traumatic experiences when
they're doing these lateralized eye
movements not vertical eye movements
they somehow separate out the negative
emotions and I thought for years people
would ask me about this stuff Tom and I
thought this is ridiculous first of all
I'm a vision scientist and I work on
stress like there's no way and then I
really ate my words because four papers
two Inhumans two in mice and then a
fifth paper published in nature which is
kind of our Super Bowl of scientific
publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection Center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of when the way that we view the
visual world when we move through space
when our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements are what
happens when you move forward in space
when you're walking when you're moving
forward towards something and that
suppresses activation of the amygdala
now you say why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there
was an actual graduate student in my
laboratory where we're looking at fear
in this case we're looking at fear to
Big looming objects that either trigger
freezing or running and hiding there's a
brain area that's in your brain and my
brain that mice also have that triggers
a third option not run and hide not
freeze but forward confrontation this is
the no I'm gonna fight I'm gonna move
forward in the face of adversity this is
the growth mindset I'm going to lean
into friction and it turns out that this
circuit is linked to the dopamine reward
pathway when we move forward in the face
of a threat and obviously we want to do
this in healthy adaptive ways we
suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with EMDR because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection Center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive mind
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space so to make this a
little more succinct it's really forward
movement action pushing yourself across
that threshold not only rewards you but
it suppresses activity of the fear
centers in the brain and these are
ancient hardwired mechanisms these
aren't hacks these are things that
mother nature installed in us there are
other things that if it's a physical
skill that you're trying to learn
as opposed to just a mental skill then
there's a whole Kingdom of things that
are fun for instance if it's a physical
skill you want to generate as many
repetitions as you safely can per unit
time so if you say I'm going to learn
dance you want the ball machine if
you're playing tennis exactly you
literally want to generate repetitions
and in particular you want to generate
failures every time you you give a bad
serve playing tennis oh yeah that
activates the circuits for focus and
alertness for the next yeah it's true
that's right so when you're losing
that's right so so that and a lot of
people don't like failures and so they
back away from it so remember the
nervous system will only change if you
give it a reason to do that and the
other one that's kind of an interesting
Twist on this is the way the nervous
system is wired is it wants to pass off
all of its work to circuits that are
reflexive as much as it can you don't
think about walking anymore because you
learned how to walk but when you were
learning you were very focused on sure
one of the things that can set the stage
for more plasticity overall is when you
disrupt the vestibular or the balance
system it does appear that whenever we
are physically off balance the brain is
primed to pay attention and the milk the
chemical milieu is such that it can
actually rewire itself faster and
whereas I think the 90s and 2000s
brought out a lot of important work on
saying hey
exercise of aerobic type or maybe even
weight training can create
neuroplasticity
it was that was great but it wasn't
directed enough it didn't say well what
kind of exercise yeah and what will get
me even more plasticity and so there are
some basal things about heart rate and
blood flow Etc but anything that
involves balance or coordination it's
incredible how fast the brain can learn
so things like dance martial arts a real
sport not just exercising and I'm not no
disrespect to the the expert I'm more of
a just an exerciser than a sport guy
um but if you're 40 50 60 80 whatever
learning a new physical skill
we know is tremendously powerful for
opening up neuroplasticity broadly so
some people will even leverage this
where after they finish some physical
skill learning or something they might
take a 20-minute nap and then they might
read or they might try something so when
we see these people they're learning
surfing I'm like 60 years old
and I'm like yes exactly exactly I
learned started learning tennis when I
was 45 and it's really a challenge
because it's not automatic and I have to
really focus and be present well these
and these individual cases are are not
necessarily the place to hang our hat
completely but for instance the great
physicist Richard Feynman he was well
known for learning bongo drums in the
sick when he was in it was in the 60s
but in his 60s then he became a quite
accomplished
um painter later in life and you know
his whole thing was approach all of
these things from a standpoint of play
with intense Focus yeah and I think the
play element is key because the play
element keeps the agitation in check so
that when you're stepping on your
partner's feet trying to learn how to
dance answer you're failing miserably it
it can frustration is a real thing and
so I think that the element of
playfulness some people call it
beginner's mind but I think that should
be the Anchor Point to return to and
people that maintain curiosity or I
should say that cultivate curiosity and
that cultivate a sense of play and
willingness to take on new vestibular
experiences of all things they
show very they show remarkable
plasticity into their late life and I
think that it all comes back to this
thing that the brain won't change unless
something changes in the weather of the
brain the overall milieu has to say oh
wait everything that's about to happen
is different yeah otherwise why would it
change dopamine is not just about reward
it's one of the biggest misconceptions
dopamine is about motivation and drive
it's like a jet that propels you along a
path how do we get more dopamine you
practice subjectively releasing dopamine
in your mind like wow okay so that's a
great question first of all there are
ways you can get more dopamine release
through thoughts or through drugs or
through supplements I want to be really
clear there is a drug there are two
drugs actually that will cause massive
release of dopamine they're called
cocaine and methamphetamine the problem
is addicted because it feels so good the
problem is exactly the problem is
cocaine and methamphetamine is stimulate
so much dopamine release that the drug
becomes the only source it becomes the
goal of your path it becomes the path
and the destination and you look at
people's lives when they do a lot of
cocaine and methamphetamine and that
Baseline on their life goes down
dopamine is this incredibly powerful
molecule that allows us to buffer the
effort process it allows us to be in
effort longer and it allows us to
actually eventually enjoy the process of
effort and not think about the reward
but just say oh I'm enjoying the process
right well you just described the first
step the first step in learning to
attach dopamine to the effort process
which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming the key to
this is if we want to be very concrete
we should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas young
people's circumstance is different let's
say somebody really wants to take on a
fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay great but to sustain that
behavior or even to make the behavior
pleasureful and to give you energy the
key is to subjectively reward those
steps so it's not going to be let's say
I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with the singles is made up
of you know single steps but the key is
to reward the harder steps not the
easier ones and not the ones where you
get the thing that you want there's a
process I'm going through right now
where I'm trying to write a book and um
it's hard it's hard and I was told that
the harder it is the better I'm probably
doing it I was like great and my editor
is ready to kill me and because I'm slow
and I and I know and I'm a very slow
person I drive people crazy I'm like
glacially slow because science is slow
and I like to get things right I want to
rush it yeah I like to get things right
but I'm very proud of the fact that
everything we've published I can stand
behind it was the best we could do with
the tools at the time and I just know
that when I look back on a writing
career or scientific career I want to be
able to say you know every Journal we
put in was Rock Solid everything was
Rock Solid we had fun doing it the
relationship so I go slow yeah but as a
consequence what I'm finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days I'm I'm I think social media is
great I teach Neuroscience on social
media because I think it's important to
do public education distraction too but
it's incredible and it's it's incredible
how much time and energy it can take so
what I've started doing now is I turn
off my phone and I lock it in a safe and
I experience extreme anxiety right it's
so weird why is that is it because it
gives you so much dopamine that when
you're not having it well this is scary
because I actually think
um brief anecdote on the weekend I was
driving there's a kid that I mentor and
I picked up my phone I was texting while
I was driving and he said to me it was
really embarrassing for me he said you
know I
I wish you wouldn't text while you drive
and I put it and I put it down and I
realized this is crazy I know that I
that my life and his life is far more
important and the lives of the people
around me are far more important than
any text message which means I wasn't
think doing it rationally it's just pure
reflex at this point so I was I don't
think I'd pick up the phone because I'm
I don't even know what I'm looking for
there anymore it's just become reflexive
so
for me lately the longer I can keep that
phone in a safe and right on a grant or
my or this book what I tell myself is
the agitation is good I'm it's at least
I'm not doing that and then I find that
as I start to write and I get into the
process I start feeling good about it
and I I'll pause and say okay I I have
control I have ultimate control over my
behavior I can put that thing away there
might be a nuclear war out there and I'm
just doing this anyway I have control
over my thoughts my feelings and
behavior so I tell myself that and then
I find I have immense energy and all I
want to do is write and I kind of tunnel
into the process wow and I think that
sometimes people need to write these
things out for themselves so it's really
concrete I think some people are so
unskilled at subjective rewards that
writing it out is really powerful so
what would you write out for yourself as
a subjective reward for this experience
as long as I'm writing I'm on the right
path as long as I'm not writing I'm
looking at my phone I'm not on the right
path because for me the the two or three
things that are most important for my
career are writing grants working on
this book manuscript and writing
scientific manuscripts I mean there are
other things anything else that you're
not doing is is holding you back from
doing that that's right so you need to
be focused Center Mass forward on doing
those things that's right so I don't do
any jumping around power poses things
like that I will use tools to kind of
ramp up my dope I mean there are certain
songs that are really embedded in my
emotionally my emotional thing they'd go
back to you know when I was a you know
wild you know skateboarding punk rock
teenager that will get me fired up and
though I think there's real utility
that's pure dopamine there's an
interesting process that
um that occurs when people start to
realize that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control this idea of duration
path and outcome and attach an internal
sense of reward just that you're doing
well to reward yourself mentally just
say I'm doing well I'm actually on the
right path
to do that inside of the
demands that come from the external
world the more often that we can
self-reward some aspect of the process
provided it's in the right direction of
what we're trying to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more Focus we're going to have
for that and remember the nor the reason
I say energy I don't throw that around
Loosely is that limiting amount of
noradrenaline is constantly being kept
at Bay you're literally buffering the
quit response and so when people start
realizing that if they set the goals
inside of the larger goal and
self-reward each one of those they
essentially have an infinite amount of
energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most uh in the Special Operations
community and people that are selected
essentially for this process it's one of
the things that's been intriguing to me
I have some friends from the SEAL Teams
and I don't begin to you know really
understand the real work that they do
deployed because I've never done that
kind of work but I've always been
intrigued by the selection process the
so-called buds process right because
carrying logs and getting in cold water
and all that that's not really how the
work is that's really not what the work
is about so the selection process is
interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit I mean I think like
there might be a couple to show up to
show up but everybody is absolutely
convinced and then a very small subset
of them make it through and I'd be
willing to bet that the ones that make
it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's a reward process
maybe it's through self-punishment maybe
it's through self-reward
um in the positive sense but they're
able to control something inside an
environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors and
I've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to not in order to get
through you just have to not quit
remember people aren't being deselected
they're not saying get out of here
you're not good enough you're not people
are deciding that for themselves and so
it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and I believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters and the
people when I say manage I think that
the people they get through knowing some
of these people quite well had an
internal process by which they could
reward themselves for doing something
that might have just looked trivial to
everybody else but it gave them more gas
more energy right right and what's
interesting is the process the the kind
of unconscious Genius of of the buds
process is that they've picked two
sensory events that are
across the board challenging for
everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you right it's not like heat
which can kill you it's cold water and
sleep deprivation and so the ability to
do these like what I'm calling dpos this
uh duration path and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know uh you know when
you have a when you have well-fed well
slept you can do anything you can be in
any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is these deep reserves of
the nervous system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us pay more
attention to how we feel than the
demands of the world around us remember
that yeah basic challenge in the nervous
system and so sleep deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because it's
very easy again rested to do all this
but so what they do is they're sleep
deprived people they put them in cold
water they're trying to get them more in
touch with the way that they feel inside
than what they need to do in response to
the external demands right everyone I
know that's made it through that process
did it slightly differently but I'll
tell you how they didn't do it they
didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by micro slicing the day or slicing the
day into a series of meals that they
just need to get to and then rewarding
themselves for getting to that next
Milestone so they don't know I mean most
of them you know probably had very low
concept of dopamine and norepinephrine
but that's the process that's also the
process I think that allows someone to
finish an ultra I've never run an ultra
but I think that process of self-reward
is grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and I
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and I think it's therefore I think
it's it's so key because I think people
think that uh it's just so key that
people understand excuse me that these
circuits are not unique to people who
run Ultras or people that make it
through uh you know stringent filter
Special Operations Command yeah it's the
same thing that it is interesting an
ability to control your levels of stress
in real time is extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and Neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down this creates more space in your
thoracic cavity and your heart actually
gets a little bit bigger as a
consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down
signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up in other words inhaling speed
your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity
as a consequence blood flows more
quickly through that smaller volume the
sinoatrial node registers that and sends
a signal to your brain and the Brain
sends a signal to slow the heart down so
in other words inhaling speeds your
heart rate up exhaling slows your heart
rate down so if you want to speed up
your heart rate and be more alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense if you want to
calm down you can do that quickly by
making your exhale slightly longer than
your inhales or making them more
vigorous
this doesn't require any breath work
this is something that you can do in
real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase It's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
HRV but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time if you want to learn and
change your brain as an adult there has
to be a high level of focus and
engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
because so focus and intensity and that
kind of the the Goggins phenotype right
I think Gog is now a noun a verb and a
pronoun right it's like it's amazing so
if you're going to goggens this process
we need to do is you need to regardless
of how agitated you feel you have to
lean in and focus extremely hard now the
reason for that is that there's a
neurochemical norepinephrine also called
adrenaline same thing that's released in
the brain and body most people back off
at that point because they feel this
agitation but we have to remember that
that neurodrenaline was designed to get
us into movement that's the purpose of
noradrenaline to take us out of
Stillness and into movement and then the
other thing we have to do is we have to
take that elevated level of alertness
and we have to focus it and there's a
second neuromodulator called
acetylcholine which is secreted from
this little structure in the base of the
forebrain when we visually focus on
something or in the case of maybe if
you're doing auditory learning when you
focus with your auditory attention no
neuroplasticity is triggered when
urgency and focus combine acetylcholine
is released for the aficionados out
there it's called the nucleus basalus
but that doesn't matter there's a little
compartment of neurons in the base of
your forebrain that doesn't like to
release acetylcholine on a regular basis
it's a it's greedy it's greedy and it
doesn't want to use that with your child
it'll drain your brain with
acetylcholine but as an adult 30 40
updates because the you know Mother
Nature designed us to learn what we need
to learn and then do that reproduce and
die I mean not to be you know how real
dark about it but I would say evolution
is not about us it's about The Offspring
yes like 100 you know it's and then it's
not even about them it's about their
offspring exactly never ends we are
being manipulated From the Inside Yes I
mean that's what it you know it kind of
Drew Me In neurobiology is that all
these complex things you see in the
world it's all internal so
you know if you get urgency it can come
from let's use David as a he's a shining
example of this right you can sit there
and just ramp up your level of urgency
through purely psychological means you
could take an ice bath you could do high
intensity breathing anything that brings
your level of alertness up understanding
that pain and pleasure in this really
dynamic balance can also help us which
in the following way any pain that you
feel the longer day the less sleep the
the kind of Agony that things aren't
working that power outlet doesn't work
or the Internet is slow whatever it is
the amount of pleasure that you will
eventually experience
is directly relation related excuse me
to how much pain you experience so we
know this from actually what nowadays
would be considered quite barbaric and
unethical experiments where they would
give people electrical shocks and they
would measure their response and then
they'd say we're going to increase it
we're going to increase it eventually
they get to the point where a slight
shock that was previously very painful
actually evokes a sense of pleasure now
you couldn't do these experiments
anymore these are not the experiments I
do in my lab these are older experiments
but for instance I and this has been
discussed in scientific research papers
giving somebody a like a 10 minute ice
bath for instance or even a three-minute
ice bath where a one minute ice bath is
quite painful but there was a study from
the University of Prague a European
Journal of physiology showed that after
a painful ice bath stimulus the amount
of dopamine release goes up for two and
a half hours to 250 percent above
Baseline and that's not because the ice
bath itself evokes dopamine release a
lot of people think oh cold water evokes
dopamine release No Pain evokes dopamine
release after the pain is over yesterday
I tweaked my back because I do this
stupid thing every few years the same
stupid thing and it's really painful and
then you just remember all the ways in
which you can't move around I was like
standing up this morning I'm like ah and
just walking is so painful as the pain
has started to dissipate you get a
little bit of a high right you get a
little bit of a Euphoria that's dopamine
because of the the degree of pain you
experienced previously predicts how much
pleasure sure so when you start a
company down in the dregs and you're
shoveling again
that's beautiful because that means that
the win that you achieve is going to be
as good or greater than the one you had
previously in your case with Quest and
so we go back to this example the person
that's not motivated that can't get off
the couch that doesn't want to do
anything well this is the problem we
remember the rad experiment they are
effectively the rat with no dopamine but
they can still achieve some sense of
pleasure by consuming excess calories by
consuming social media and look I'm not
judging I do this stuff too right
scrolling social media if you've ever
scrolled social media and you're like I
don't even know why I'm doing this it
doesn't really feel that good
and I can remember a time where you'd
see something it was just so cool or you
see something online I remember this
when TED Talks first came out I was like
this is amazing these are some at least
some of them are really smart people
sharing really cool insights and then
now that they're like a gazillion TED
Talks I remember spending a winter in my
office at when I was a junior Professor
cleaning my office finally and binging
TED talks in the background thinking
there's a good use of my time pretty
soon they all sucked to me I was like
this isn't good so what you need to do
is stop watching TED talks for a while
wait and then they become interesting
again and that's this pain pleasure
balance and so for people that aren't
feeling motivated the problem is they're
not motivated but they're getting just
enough or excess sustenance so they're
getting the little mild hits of opio it
becomes an opioid system and if you
think about the opioid drugs as opposed
to dopamine dopaminergic drugs
dopaminergic drugs make people rabid for
everything you know drugs of abuse like
cocaine and amphetamine make people
incredibly outward directed right they
hardly notice anything except what they
want more of more it's very it's bad
because those drugs trigger so much
dopamine release that they become the
reward it's very circular the only the
drug can give that much dope I mean
nothing they could pursue would give
them as much dopamine as the drug itself
so there's that and then there's the
kind of opioid like effects of
constantly indulging oneself with social
media or with video games or with uh
with food or with anything to the point
where it no longer evokes the motivation
in craving and this is really the New
Evolution of the understanding of
dopamine and Neuroscience which is that
dopamine itself is not the reward it's
the build up to the reward and the
reward has more of a kind of opioid
Bliss like property which itself is not
bad if it's endogenous released from
within but when we can just sit there
like they're like the rat with no
dopamine gorging ourselves with
Pleasures so to speak what you end up
with is somebody that feels really
unmotivated and those Pleasures no
longer work to tickle those feel-good
circuits and so there's no reason for
them to go out and pursue anything and
that's a pretty dark picture so the the
keys are to pursue rewards but
understand that the pursuit is actually
the reward if you want to have repeated
wins okay you the celebration has to be
less than the pursuit and that's hard
for some people to do they you know that
they it's got to be that your
celebration is slightly less
dopaminergic it can be very reflective
you can be in gratitude those are other
neurotransmitter systems but you don't
want to be on that high as you celebrate
the win
you want to be
trickling out your dopamine regularly
until you pursue things to what extent
does our subjective narrative the story
the story We Tell ourselves actually
means something for the body and to what
extent does the body actually mean
something for the subjective narrative
so this gets into some areas of work
that we're doing now and so I do want to
highlight that it's ongoing work but I
think you know the old narrative meaning
a few 10 years ago was that if you're
feeling depressed just smile well if
that worked right we would have a lot
less depression than we see out right
the reason I call it a brain body
contract early on is that their the
brain and the body are constantly in
dialogue so you know the idea that when
we're depressed we tend to be in more
defensive type postures when we're
feeling good we tend to be in more like
relaxed and extended postures all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that I'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going that's how
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective there is one way in which
subjective thought and deliberate
thought is very powerful Over States of
mind and body to answer your question
can you think your way out of the ice
bath being cold so a couple things that
are important first of all just to go a
little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now I can
say okay have a thought that just decide
to write your name and you're you can do
that I'm going to decide to write on him
and you can do it so that's a deliberate
thought which says that you can
introduce thoughts so I think it's very
hard to control negative thoughts
directly by trying to suppress them
generally they tend to just want to
continue to geyser up all the time but
we can introduce a positive thought when
people think of hypnosis I think they
think of stage hypnosis what's the real
deal why is it useful and and how do
people actually use it yeah so um I'm
really glad you asked about this so I
have a colleague his name is David
Spiegel and our department of Psychiatry
at Stanford and he and I have a
collaboration going now looking at how
respiration or breathing can be used to
shift the brain into different states
and I've talked to David about this and
so I'm sort of borrowing from his words
here so I want to be fair that these are
from those conversations so hypnosis
inevitably involves relaxing the nervous
system taking the nervous system into
states that are more like sleep now what
I mean by that is in high alert states
where you're talking and planning and
inaction and stress in particular the
brain is very linear it's saying okay if
this then this if then then this is why
we tend to be forward-thinking when
we're when we're stressed we tend to be
not in our immediate experience but
really kind of forward thinking so
clinical hypnosis involves
going into a state of deeper relaxation
so that our analysis of space and time
meaning the way that the brain is
perceiving events is slightly dismantled
so that it's a little bit dreamlike and
then the hypnotist and this could be by
listening to a script or listening to a
hypnotherapist
starts to narrow our context take our
thoughts if you will it down a
particular path and that path could be
one of
um stress reduction or a smoking
cessation
um hypnosis is incidentally is very good
for treatment of smoking cessation or
for feelings of well-being or
confronting traumas so what it is is
it's really opening up the window for
neuroplasticity which is of course the
brain's ability to change in response to
experience to trigger neuroplasticity
you have to have Focus especially as an
adult you need acetylcholine released
but high levels of attention
acetylcholine and norepinephrine
together norepinephrine to create that
sense of urgency and acetylcholine to
bring that Spotlight of focus in really
really tight that triggers plasticity
but the actual it marks certain synapses
in the brain for change but the actual
changes in the synapses the rewiring
okay that happens during states of sleep
and deep rest so this is why when you're
trying to learn a motor skill you go and
you go in your tennis serve it's not
happening it's not happening you take a
break you come back and you nail it
you're like wait what happened well you
need time to set those circuits in
motion and allow them to do to rewiring
the sort of adaptation hypnosis seems to
capture both the high attentional State
and the deep relaxation at the same time
it's this very unusual State of Mind
where you're neither asleep nor awake
and in tight Focus or narrow focus and
it's very clear that it leads to these
rapid changes in Behavior because you're
rewiring the brain and the reason you're
able to rewire the brain so quickly is
because you're getting the trigger event
the focus and you're also getting the
relaxation event simultaneously and so
it's much faster than separating out the
learning trigger from the actual
rewiring of the brain previously I told
you that it's great to foreshadow
failure that that's a great way to get
your system into a state of activation I
also told you that you want to set goals
that are challenging but possible and
again here I'm paraphrasing from the
work of Emily balsetis I want to be very
clear
there are a few other things that one
can do in order to bias the likelihood
that you will succeed in trying to
achieve your goals first of all limit
your options
trying to pursue too many goals at once
can definitely be counterproductive now
I realize that life is complicated we
all have multiple goals that we're
trying to pursue but if we have
particular goals that are important to
us we have to be careful to not get
distracted by other goals and many
people run into this problem so setting
one or two or maybe three major goals
for a given year is going to be more
than enough for most people and is
actually going to be challenging for
most people now of course we have daily
goals and monthly goals and yearly goals
but if we have big lofty goals we need
to be careful not to contaminate our
mental space and our visual space with
too many goals and why do I say visual
goals well
what various department stores and
supermarkets have discovered is that the
greater the number of things in our
visual attention the more that we can
draw our attention and our goals off a
line of pursuit what does that mean well
let's think about in the Practical
context this has actually been done big
department stores have figured out that
if they stock their shelves
chock-a-block with many many options of
food or clothing items or objects or
anything like that people simply buy
more stuff people are very prone to
orienting their attention to whatever's
in front of them you put a lot of stuff
in front of them their attention drifts
you put fewer things in front of them
their attention is more narrow
in a later episode we'll talk about
designing a workspace that's optimized
on the basis of this it doesn't mean
being in a room with nothing except just
your desk and a computer doesn't have to
be that sparse but visual sparseness
actually can help us Orient our focus
and our behavior when we have a lot of
things in our visual environment or a
lot of things in our cognitive
environment it's the same thing and so
if you're going to try and pursue a
fitness goal a relationship goal an
academic goal and a long-term Life
Financial goal all at once that's four
things and you're going to have to come
up with systems that allow you to
isolate those goals in a very rigid way
I'm a big fan of wellness and and I
think it's a great Community but it
tends to run in absolutes and there and
there aren't a lot of operational
definitions as we say in science and I
what I love about your questions you're
asking for really getting to the meat of
things asking for the operational
definitions one of the most dangerous
ideas in wellness and in popular
psychology is that your body hears every
thought you have what a terrible thing
to put on people
what a challenging thing I don't think
people should try and suppress their
negative thoughts I think there is Great
Value however to introducing positive
thought schemes now the reason is not
because I think it's just because I
think so but because there's actually a
neurochemical basis for controlling
stress and actually making stress more
tolerable and extending one's ability to
be in bouts of effort and that relates
to the dopamine pathway
so the molecule dopamine is a reward
it's released in the brain when you win
a game you you know close a deal
like your photo the great love of your
life you complete something but most of
our dopamine release is not from
achieving goals it's actually released
when we are enroute to our goals where
we're in pursuit of our goals and we
think we're on the right path there was
a paper published that essentially was
asking why any human or animal quits at
any Behavior now certain behavior is
like I can't lift a car unless it's a
very small car I can't lift a car but if
it's we're talking about running or
we're talking about long bouts of work
the question is why do we quit like what
is that it turns out that every time we
exert effort a certain amount of
noradrenaline in the brain is released
and there's a sort of a counter in the
brain stem and at some point enough
noradrenaline is released and it shuts
down cognitive control deliberate
control over the motor circuitry and we
quit that's it but the thing that can
restore those levels or can sort of
reset those levels lower and give us
more gas more mileage is dopamine and it
makes perfect sense because our species
had to move against very challenging
things in in nature and in in terms of
in culture at every stage of our
Evolution including now 2020 is a good
example of this and when a good example
would be if you're really slogging it
out and things are miserable just think
like the worst family vacation
everything's a disaster or a very hard
physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you're almost immediately feel a sense
of relief you see this in the team that
wins the Super Bowl both teams slogged
it out you have to believe they were
both at Max effort the entire game look
at the team that wins they have extra
energy they're jumping all over the
place so it can't be physical energy it
can't be glycogen related it's not
Ketone related it's nothing in the body
in that sense it's dopamine's ability to
take that level of norepinephrine and
smack it back down and so we can learn
this right I mean I think this is where
there's real power like in your story
um or the story that I'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through those pain points is
something that we really can export to
other aspects of life because it's the
same neurochemicals that are involved so
when you get to a particular location or
maybe you're I recall
um you know a portion where you're just
you're feeling lousy you know you're
injured or you feel like you're hurt and
you can reframe it mentally
and think I'm actually still on the
ladder I'm still holding on to a rung I
know at least that much I'm still
breathing I know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
it's dopamine suppressing norepinephrine
and saying you're on the right path you
can keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us I think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that external rewards can
actually Propel us down long past of of
success and high performance they can't
no it's internal sustainable fuel source
yeah yeah I have a friend from the SEAL
Teams and somebody asked us recently we
were given a talk um and somebody said
how can I make sure that I continue to
self-reward and I'm not driven by these
external rewards how can I continue to
have that drive and uh his answer was
very good he said give away all the
external rewards you know now not all
everyone can afford to do this just
about you and you it's just you and you
and the more attached there's a famous
Stanford study done at Bing Nursery
School probably not far where from where
you were in the dormitory there's a
little Nursery School in Escondido
Village
and they did a study where they looked
at kids that like to um playing during
their recess it's all recess in nursery
school but they're drawing and they took
the kids that really like to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings and then they
like the gold stars for a kid that's an
extrinsic reward and then they stopped
doing that and the kids stopped drawing
they just they they associate the good
feeling of doing it with the external
rewards we have to be very cautious
about how much of our internal dopamine
we attach to external rewards if we want
to continue to grow and pursue and focus
and work hard if you just want to get to
some place and cash in
then fine but most people find
themselves in a pretty miserable place
because their dopamine was so attached
to external rewards they need more and
more well a lot of people
hashtag growth mindset is one of the
most popular hashtags in social media
but most people don't actually know what
it means and then again this is Carol
dweck's discovery not mine it was
discovered in a group of kids that were
doing math problems or other kinds of
puzzles that they knew they couldn't get
right but they enjoyed doing them and
they perform exceedingly well on lots of
sorts of tests of that sort when there
is the right answer of course and so
what they do is they've somehow they're
wired for effort they're wired for the
puzzle not for the solution and when I
say puzzle I don't mean the noun puzzle
I mean the verb for being puzzled it for
them feels good and so we need to think
if we're talking about the nervous
system and we want to make it actionable
for high performance whether or not it's
in business or sport or otherwise we
want to think in terms of processes not
events events and verbs not nouns so
growth mindset as a verb as an action
item you know a reward as a verb not
just as a oh you're gonna just pat
yourself on the back like it's no it's
what you internalize it's a process
that's how the neural circuits that
underlie reward get stronger and the
beauty of the brain is that you have
this thing of neuroplasticity which is
its ability to change itself throughout
the whole lifespan and the more you
practice this the better you get at it
and it does not mean you're walking
around talking delusionally about how
great life is when everything is
terrible it means you might even be very
stoic you might be hopefully you're very
rational but you have the energy to
continue to push forward
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you think that
your thoughts have something to do with
your future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create
Your Destiny and you think 60 to 70 000
thoughts in one day and 90 of those
thoughts